قال مجلس السياده الانتقال بالسودان ان
رئيس المجلس عبد الفتاح البرهان التقى
اليوم في مكتبه في الخرطوم وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي
والوفد المرافقه له
وتطرق اللقاء الى سبل ارساء علاقات مثمره
بين اسرائيل والسودان وتعزيز افاق التعاون
المشترك بين الخرطوم وتل ابيب في عده
مجالات لا سيما الامنيه والعسكريه وبحسب
اعلام مجلس السياده فقد حث الجانب
السوداني الجانب الاسرائيلي على العمل على
تحقيق الاستقرار بين اسرائيل والشعب
الفلسطيني كما تناول اللقاء الدور الذي
يلعبه السودان في معالجه القضايا الامنيه
في المنطقه
وكانت رويترز قد نقلت عن مصدرين بالحكومه
السودانيه تاكيدهما ان وفدا اسرائيليا وصل
اليوم الى الخرطوم لبحث تطبيع العلاقات
بين البلدين
واضافت الوكاله ان زياره جزء من تبادل
للزيارات بين السودان واسرائيل وتشمل بحث
التوصل الى اتفاق للتطبيع والتوقيعه
وكانت طائره اسرائيليه قد هبطت في مطار
الخرطوم وكشفت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان
طائره التي تحمل اسم فور اكس يوزد اقلعت
من مطار تل ابيب فجرا متوجهه الى السودان